so let's talk about the most important
thing yeah uh who yeah obviously uh who
picked out Valentino because I'm also
wearing Valentino oh yeah I thought the
Tyrell Corporation was a dead giveaway
uh I well I'm in Italy you know what I
mean I felt like I should wear uh a
reputable Italian designer who better
than Valentino okay I I have creating it
by the way thank you thank you I tried
actually they told me to dress business
casual there it is that's your business
it is actually so I have to know what
it's like because I know I've known you
a long time and I know you're a full-on
geek everyone knows this if like can you
imagine telling yourself when you were
making space and just breaking in all
the crazy [__] you have done in your
career and like your reaction I I
sometimes think that and I wonder I
would love to go back and just tell
myself because I would have an absolute
you know conniption fit it's it's kind
of mind-blowing you and I met 20 years
ago next year Comic-Con 2004. holy F and
that was when we were kind of out there
kind of pushing Sean of the Dead which
no one had seen at the time and yeah
lots happens is that what's funny is I
remember that Comic-Con and walking
around the convention floor with you and
you go I remember this story you go into
the ATM just take out money no one knows
who you are just like enjoying the ride
yeah it was amazing we all went up to
someone's hotel room and we watched the
digital cuts of Empire and stuff and do
you remember dude
reminisce on camera exactly or us
hanging out at the Arc Light just taking
random pictures no one knowing anything
oh yeah in the bookstore yeah anyway
professionalism right exactly so uh how
many behind the scenes videos do you
have of Tom on set doing cool stuff and
which one is your favorite I have a
video on my phone of the motorcycles
done of me like from the side just going
I was stood with Tarzan palm and Hayley
and I and I've got the whole thing and I
zoom in and he goes off and he just
disappears and you hear us just go
silent as we're waiting to hear that you
know he's alive and then we all just
laugh like children like giddy
ridiculous insane children because the
relief I cannot tell you the relief was
it was you know amazing my last thing
for you because I know you had to talk
to other people I'm very excited for the
new season of the boys yeah so what can
you tease I can tease you know the boys
you know how crazy the boys is it's
gonna get crazier I had so much fun on
that show it was so great to go back and
play Hugh senior I love Jack it was
great to work with Rose DeWitt who plays
Huey's mom you know who comes back uh
it's gonna be great You're Gonna Love of
it are you you're in I think two
episodes I'm in I'm in about four
episodes oh my bad yeah yeah yeah and it
was it was a joy to be back it's a great
crew there are an amazing bunch of
people uh and that show is sick as [__]
it really is on that note sure congrats
this movie's incredible thank you Steve